hello there I I can't do that on every
Obi-Wan video okay so this was a day of
reveals and surprises man we got a new
Valkyrie Profile game coming out we have
a Ninja Turtles Retro Game Collection
coming out a thing we got that I did not
expect not that I expected the other two
was a trailer for The Obi-Wan Kenobi
series because this is it this is the
story The Star Wars fans myself included
have wanted to see since
birth now we have a trailer for this
story this series that I really
threw up as far as trailers go it starts
out amazing and just it's a really good
trailer for the moment you have Obi-Wan
Kenobi talking like the fighting's over
we lost I mean technically speaking you
didn't you won you just didn't know you
didn't want to win you fought for
Palpatine's government Palpatine's
government won I get it you were
deceived by a lie we all were and that
right there I love that line I love a
lot of lines in this trailer to be
honest but I love that line because that
really does reflect what I've wanted to
see in an Obi-Wan Series this person
who's just like
we lost I lost my world not just my
world I trained the guy who became one
of the guys who destroyed the world not
same Planet I've seen world world can
Encompass an entire galaxy when the
Galaxies all interconnected as it is in
Star Wars and the moment that Duel of
the Fates
lucasfilm and just blows away like sand
I was like huh okay great music choice
great music choices in this trailer Duel
of the face really kicks it on uh that's
getting a lot of the conversation but
Battle of the heroes from Revenge of the
Sith that's also in there Duel of the
Fate starts it out the entire the Crux
of the trailer the the meat and bones of
the music is Battle of the heroes it
looks like we're getting more space
adventure than I ever asked for for an
Obi-Wan series that takes place in this
time frame more inquisitors laser Space
Battles we know I mean Obi-Wan and Vader
are probably gonna clash in this movie
so in the meantime we have inquisitors
and I kind of have a love-hate
relationship with inquisitors at first I
totally get it because it's like no one
in Star Wars Rebels can take on Darth
Vader it's just impossible but we need
lightsaber fights all right inquisitors
Grand Inquisitor great and Rebels I you
see him in here he's pretty menacing he
has this great line in here where he's
talking about how a Jedi's code is like
an itch they can't help it so you know
just torture people and we'll bring the
Jedi out of hiding and then we just kill
him there's some pretty Sinister [ __ ] I
love that but I got to the point where
every time I would see an Inquisitor do
something I felt like it was screen time
I could have seen Vader do something
Vader's out there being like big boss
just has his Fulton system like okay you
want to work for me great boom you're an
Inquisitor now people who aren't Metal
Gear fans are like what the [ __ ] is he
talking about but on the other hand to
be fair Jedi Fallen order did The
Inquisitor storyline really well I
thought that was very well done but it
looks too and this is where we get into
you know with trailers out so now
theorizing is part of the fun of
trailers Star Wars trailers in
particular it's always been just a hub
of theorizing but it looks like the
inquisitors the Empire they've come to
Tatooine for a reason almost like
they've sense something and maybe I'm
seeing it through the goggles of I
played Jedi Fallen order so I kind of
saw that happening there someone used
the force now the inquisitors have shown
up they're like okay let's weed them out
let's kill him only thing is if that be
the case if that's what brings them
there if that's why they are on Tatooine
I'm not entirely convinced it was
Obi-Wan I'm not entirely convinced it
wouldn't be luke let's face it that'd be
kind of interesting wouldn't it like
Anakin Skywalker when he was racing pods
he was really good at pod racing because
he was at the subconscious level using
Jedi reflex as though he didn't know
what it was he didn't know what he was
doing he's had good reflexes I could see
something like that happening with Luke
where Luke just subconsciously I don't
know he does something bull sizes womp
rats with his t16 and maybe he's a
little young to do that but I was
tattooing that plan is not exactly up to
code it's not exactly the safest place
in the Galaxy I'm sure kids start
bullseyeing their womp rats at age three
it'd be interesting to see if the
inquisitors show up because they sense
the force being used and whether or not
that was Luke and that would answer that
question the question of why is Uncle
Owen such a grumpy dick in a new hope I
can see it being a case where he's like
dude we took this kid in because I was
his uncle I felt like it was the right
thing to do then he moved a grain of
sands on the ground with his mind and
now these Super Evil space Wizards are
coming trying to kill him you know what
Luke guess what good news you get to be
a farmer forever but you have hopes and
dreams you have [ __ ] that [ __ ] farmer
forever Harvest is when I need you the
most we knee-deep in Twilight so you can
me trust me this is the life God willing
we all get to die old grumpy ass men one
day guess you'll get to do that even
when you are a Jedi
that's unexpected there's a good trailer
I I just really hope they keep it in the
pocket here I'm seeing a lot of
inquisitors do a lot of Inquisitor
things and as much as it does a lot the
opportunity does afford the opportunity
to show Jedi being hunted down or at
least the process of it something again
we did see in Jedi fall in order so
there is that I don't want it to be like
oh Obi-Wan Kenobi should have been
called the inquisitors keeping the
family Dynamic at the center of Owen
Luke Vader Obi-Wan Obi-Wan's family
keeping that family Dynamic at the
center using the inquisitors to
basically get it churning but not having
the inquisitors hijack the series
that'll be the test right there that's
where balance comes in so we'll see what
happens but I had to do a video on this
because thus far that Obi-Wan Kenobi
trailer that was a great trailer the
biggest question I have on my mind in
this trailer is does that Inquisitor
know that that is her boss's stepbrother
alright so the Obi-Wan Kenobi trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it are you looking forward to the
Obi-Wan Kenobi series do you have faith
in it whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]